uh so what do you got going on right now
ma'am [ __ ] I'm uh I'm getting ready to
drop I got my project money Family
respect from the drop okay I've been
working on that I probably invested more
time than money in it in terms of just
like shooting videos features Beats
Audio times just
trying to put all the right [ __ ]
together and really just taking my time
with it right just not rushing it you
feel like in in the past you will Rush
your projects no not really but this one
I just really sat down and just waited
it's like all right
a couple months all right what's the
best songs right now send them to daybo
see how you feel put that to the side
and then come back later when we ready
to drop
and really order sorted out right who's
on the album
I got ogz
baby money shout out to uh baby money uh
Mazzy emazi of course
uh low blood and a little goofy shots a
little blood
I don't wanna forget nobody but I think
that's really it though oh Millie's my
boy my caucasian brother Millie That's
my boy that's my [ __ ] boy I [ __ ] with
them Millie's on there and uh TJ TJ 3K
okay does that have to do from Detroit
to be scamming no no what's the guy's
name from Detroit to be scamming his is
six two oh six that's what I'm thinking
about yeah it's similar yeah now shout
out to uh to Millie's Milly's is fire
that guy's just stays with a wife beater
and a pair of fresh air forces